hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde wir schauen uns heute sieben
geheime Nachrichten an die in
Zeichentrickfilm versteckt sind wie wir
herausstellten war Walt Disney einer der
größten Scherzkekse woher kommt das Wort
Scherzkekse überhaupt was ist das dick
an Kekse der Witz erzählt oder was habt
ihr schon mal gemerkt dass bei Aladin
das Biest aus die Schöne und das Biest
vorkommt und in der Monster AG der Fisch
Nemo zu sehen ist was
[Musik]
das ist Nemo wir sind uns sicher dass es
nur wenigen aufgefallen ist hier kommen
noch ein paar nennenswerten
Nemo einfach in mehr Disney Film gewesen
als wie wenn ich im Glöckner von Notre
Dame sieht man allerdings fliegenden
Teppich ja schöne aus die Schöne und das
Biest und Pumba aus König der Löwen
wilden was er ihnen schweinest das war
wir können ihn nicht mal mich da
irgendwie rein machen im
Zeichentrickfilm Lilo und stitch kommt
ein Elefant namens Dumbo vor der sich
auf
Alter es ist sehr der ist ja überall
irgendwie Referenz zu einem anderen Film
ich weiß nur dass bei zoomania auch in
einer Szene Micky Maus als Stoff die im
Kinderwagen auftaucht
ich habe mich so krass gefühlt als ich
das im Film entdeckt habe ich das direkt
einmal mein Freund sagt also jetzt
weiter geht's in frozen waren noch
einige Figuren aus anderen Filmen zu
Gast okay so sieht man am Ball Rapunzel
und Flynn aus tengeld Tiana und Nevin
aus Küsten Frosch und in der Szene wo
Prinzessin Anna Schuhe kauft kann man
die Figur des Mike wasowski aus der
Monster AG sehen also ich kenne nur Mike
wasowski aus der Monster geben
wie Sandra da
vor fast 89 Jahren konnte sich Walt
Disney nicht vorstellen dass eine naive
und vergessliche Maus nicht einfach
beliebt und bekannt sein wird sondern
gleich die ganze Zeichentrickwelt
verkörpert das ist halt so brutal ne
was auch so Filmen alles entstanden ist
vor ein paar Wochen habe ich auf meinem
zweitkanal Luke Schuh den ihr natürlich
alle abonniert habt
wenn nicht dann blockiere ich euch bei
Youtube jedenfall habe ich dort in dem
Video auf Fakten über die Minions
reagiert und da waren auch so crazy
facts mit dabei und dann auch was die
für ein riesiges Merchant als Franchise
Konzept daraufhin aufgebaut haben uns
das brutal also wirklich hut ab in
vielen Disney Zeichentrickfilmen gibt es
das sogenannte Phänomen der versteckten
Micky Maus es geht darum dass in vielen
Szenen plötzlich der Schatten der Micky
Maus zum Vorschein kommt oder irgendein
Objekt mit den Konturen der Maus
erscheint seht doch selbst hier ist eine
Szene aus Cinderella und die
Seifenblasen erinnern an den Micky Maus
Kopf was
oh ach so wegen Kopf linkes Ohr rechtes
Ohr aber das ist schon sehr weit
hergeholt und hier fällt Pumba vom
Wasserfall schaut her das
okay das ist
das ist schon kein Zufall mehr jetzt
seht ihr eine Unterwasserwelt und ihren
König den Molch mit Delfinen auf den
fahrleinern überall wird der
unterwasserkönig von seinen Bewohnern
erwartet doch wartet mal wer steht dort
wie ihr wahrscheinlich schon
habt da steckt so viel Liebe zum Detail
drin ne
wahrscheinlich gibt es auch wieder
tausende Skandale rund um Walt Disney
rum ich kenne mich damit jetzt nicht so
übertrieben krass aus aber die haben uns
schon alle wirklich heftig geprägt habt
ihr ein Detail gesehen dass in jedem
dieser Zeichentrickfilme vorkommt
unserer Meinung nach haben nur die
aufmerksamen von euch ein Buchstaben und
eine Zahl gesehen auch wir haben eine
Zeit lang dafür benötigt der geheime
Code A113 kommt in vielen bekannten
Zeichentrickfilmen vor aufmerksame
Zuseher die es gesehen haben dachten
zunächst ein mystische Theorien oder
einen unterschiedlichen Reiz der
absichtlich versteckt wurde
wahrscheinlich ist es einfach die
Postleitzahl von Walt Disney Headquarter
in Amerika oder so
oder die Hausnummer
aber es ist echt crazy das die sich
wahrscheinlich wirklich so ein riesen
Zettel mittlerweile an Insidern
aufgeschrieben haben und wenn sie 9 Walt
Disney Film planen sagen okay das muss
rein hier muss Micky Maus sein A113 muss
sein das muss sein A113 ist die Nummer
eines Zimmers wo die Ausbildung vieler
Zeichentrickfilm Hersteller im
kalifornischen Kunstinstitut stattfand
Leute haben zahlreiche Experten
Hollywoods grafisches Design oder
Animation gelernt jetzt könnt ihr ganz
einfach herausfinden ob der Disney
animationsexperte eine Grafik für The
Hunger Games oder Star Wars zeichnete
das ist so crazy Star Wars Hunger Games
vorhin auch in allen möglichen
Zeichentrick und Animationsfilm ich
finde das Video übelst interessant
achtung jetzt müsst ihr euch wieder
konzentrieren also liegt alles bei Seite
und seid bereit einige Male auf Pause zu
drücken okay den richtigen Zeitpunkt
nichts zu verpassen wie wir bereits
festgestellt haben lieben die Disney
Filme Ananas zu verlinken doch habt ihr
alle davon gesehen jeder Film
hinterlässt an den Hinweis auf eine
andere Animation damit ihr diesen auch
anschaut ich glaube
auch dass es in Disney Film immer bisher
so war dass sie in beispielsweise in dem
Film von 2017 irgendwas versteckt haben
wo man schon darauf schießen konnte okay
2018 wird damit ein Film stattfinden das
heißt wenn jetzt 2022 einen Film
rauskommt kann sein dass wir irgendeine
Sache dort sehen aber gar nicht krass
wahrnehmen aber wenn wir den Film dann
ein paar Jahre später gucken sie mir ach
guck mal das war der der Film kam erst
danach raus die Theorie habe ich
letztens auf tiktok gesehen unter den
Kindern am Aquarium kann man ein sehr
bekanntes Gesicht erkennen Riley die
Hauptdarstellerin von alles steht Kopf
lol was haben die Filmhersteller
hinsichtlich Emotionen in diesem Film
versteckt hier erinnert sich die Figur
an die Statue des Dinosauriers der
genauso aussieht wie forest wood Bush
aus Alu und Spot eine andere Figur aus
diesem Zeichentrickfilm hallo kann man
unter den Spielzeugen in der Monster AG
sehen das ist so verrückt
also ich weiß nicht ob ihr auch so
riesen Disney Animationsfilms Fans seid
aber ich guck halt das meiste wirklich
auf Disney plus gerade nicht bezahlt ne
aber das ist brutal im Film dick Hero 6
der 2014 herauskam gab es gleich zwei
Figuren die keinesfalls mit den Helden
in Verbindung stehen überlegt doch
selbst hallo und baymax fliegen zum
ersten Mal durch die Stadt und was ist
das dort im Hintergrund das ist doch das
Schneemann Olaf aus frozen ja gut aber
das musste erstmal erkennen ne wenn das
eine Szene von zwei Sekunden ist kannst
du nicht im Kino
ich habe auch frozen noch immer nicht
geguckt und noch eine andere Frage hieß
es wirklich big Hero keine Ahnung was
bei uns ist das baymax damals im Kino
schaut euch an wessen Foto im
Polizeirevier hängt steht diese Person
aus der Fahndungsliste wir sind gar
nicht überrascht denn es handelt sich um
prinzianz von den südenseln das ist halt
so verrückt
ich finde es echt crazy wenn in dem Film
baymax das spielt ja eigentlich so nach
realen Welt denn irgend so ein Märchen
Charakter plötzlich auftaucht nur weil
das wieder eine Korrespondenz zu einem
anderen Film ist in einigen pixarfilmen
zum Beispiel kann man das berühmte Apple
Logo erkennen seht her da ist alles auf
der Motorhaube eines Autos von Cars und
das hier rechts ist doch auch ein Pepsi
Logo oder bin ich blöd
auch Steven Spielberg kommt mit seinem
Jurassic Park in der Tiergeschichte vor
erinnert ihr euch an den laufenden T-Rex
im Seitenspiegel der Autos wie erkennt
es nicht man sagt Steven Spielberg sei
stolz darauf dass seine Werke in den
Disney Film vorkommen und Beschwerde
auch übelstolz drauf klar okay also
Jurassic Park und sowas hat er halt
erschaffen aber
man hat es wirklich und das kann ich
selber auch so ich will mich jetzt nicht
mit sieben Stil ich will mich jetzt um
Gottes Willen nicht auf irgendein
Plateau Stellen mit Steven
die mit diesem Typen da und mit
irgendjem Walt Disney und keine Ahnung
was um Gottes Willen aber ich selber
finde auch immer crazy wenn andere
Youtuber die auch so meine Größe sind
oder noch größer dann irgendwie auf mich
reagieren oder mich in ihre Videos mit
einbeziehen oder Einblendung von mir
benutzen
das fühlt sich schon geehrt so ein
bisschen obwohl man quasi selber so
einer von denen es ist ganz komisch
gerade zuletzt sehen wir uns einen
konkreten Film an The Boss Baby bestimmt
ich tatsächlich nicht gesehen
um was geht da schreibst du mal bitte in
die Kommentare und muss ich mir das
angucken keine Angst wer klären euch
alles und lassen alles voller Weg okay
in einer Szene gelangen die
Hauptdarsteller ins Revier der Gegner um
die letzte geheime Ausarbeitung zu
stehlen okay ist die Mappe in ihren
Händen ist beginnt der Stuhl auf dem sie
sich befand langsam nach unten zu sinken
erinnert dieses Szene nicht an etwas
genau an Indiana Jones wie im
Originalfilm löst auch hier ein
Mechanismus ein schlaues fallensystem
aus ja aber gut
das kann ja auch sein dass sie das gar
nicht extra gemacht haben sondern oft
macht man ja auch Sachen oder sagt Dinge
weil man sie irgendwo aufgegriffen hat
aber man will nicht extra diese
Korrespondenz schaffen die grantige
Babysitterin hat zum Beispiel einen
Bekannten Hut auf und bewegt sich mit
einem Schirm in der Luft genau wie Mary
Poppins die magische Babysitterin der
Autorin Pamela okay
ich dachte wenn du das Outfit gewesen
wäre aber aus dem Schornstein raus nur
mit diesem Ding das ist dann wiederum
schon extra gewählt glaube ich will euch
diese Anspielung nicht deutlich genug
ist kommt hier noch eine okay das Baby
richtet seinem älteren Bruder Tim die
Haare mit einem Beginn und vergiss nicht
ihm ein paar Ohrfeigen mit dem
Rasierschaum zu geben das König der
Löwen glaube ich mit dem Geld
selbstverständlich haben wir dieses
hinne schon bei Kevin von home alone
gesehen ich habe Kevin allein zu Haus
nicht gesehen
von daher kann ich mich darauf nicht
beziehen allerdings würde ich an der
Stelle des heutigen Video jetzt auch
beenden meine lieben Freunde ich fand's
ultra interessant ich finde es immer
crazy zu sehen okay wo wohnt irgendeine
geheime Botschaft versteckt oder
irgendwie so wenn es euch auch gefallen
hat dann lasst gern einen Daumen hoch
unter dem Video da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke um
weitere Videos nicht zu verpassen ich
werde mir glaube ich mal eine Boss Baby
anschauen